but i said a tweet that got people going
so i'll share it here on the show i said
if you want to know which one of your
friends is going to get divorced just
look at his wife's instagram right
and it got a lot of
god it got a lot of positive but then
some women go like what are you looking
for
and then dudes just started writing
like
selfies with no kids or no husband in
the picture
like bikini like oh my god
put it back out there dude
they're like what are you looking for is
that because they want to see who's
going to get a divorce are they trying
to cover for their own tracks well it
kind of means that if you look at your
wife's instagram and you see a bunch of
selfish narcissistic without family
stuff it's a problem
she's not satisfied she's she's still
searching